[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم انا اسمي جنى عندي تسع سنين
دلوقتي بثالثه ححكيلكم قصه النهارده
احكيلكم قصه يلقبوني فيها اخر العنقود سكر
معقود دلوعه بابا وحبيبته بس في يوم صحيت
على صوت عيلت كلهم بيعيطوا وما سالتهم في
ايه محدش محدش رد كانوا بيعيطوا بس كانوا
بيعيطوا وبس وقالوا لازم نروح لبابا عشان
بابا حصل له حاجه في الاول ماما قالت هروح
لوحده بس اللي اتصل بينا قال لنا لا
تعالوا كلكم بس اللي اتصل بينا قال لنا لا
تعالوا كلكم وانا في الطريق كنت خايفه
وبالذات علت بس صممت نفسي وقلت اكيد زي
المره اللي بات اللي دخل فيه اللي دخل
فيها العنايه المركزه ورجع لنا الحمد لله
ورجع لنا الحمد
لله ورجع لنا الحمد لله انتم عارفين انتم
عارفين انا مري انت انا اول ما رحت كل
الناس قالت لي اللي هو كده خلاص مات بس
انا اما دخلت وشفته شفته نايم بس شفتوا
نايم بس انتم عارفين انا مريت في الاختبار
او الامتحان ده ب كذا شعور منهم كذا شعور
اول شعور هو الصدمه اللي انا لا يمكن يبقى
ده حقيقي وكنت فعلا متصادمه وتاني شعور
هو
الحزن وانا اللي هو اكيد لا انا زعلانه
يعني اكيد مش هيحصل ده اكيد وثالث شعور هو
الشوق اللي انا يعني يا ريت يرجع بيا
الزمن وارجع
لبابا واهم واخر حاجه هي التقبل اللي انا
تقبلت كل حاجه بمساعده اخواتي ومامتي
مساعده اخواتي ومامتي ومامتي واخواتي
ساعدوني في حاجات
كتير وكمان كانوا بيقولوا لي عادي تزعلي
وتخافي وتعيطي فان دايما جنبي كان دايما
جنبي وفي
ضهري انتم عارفين انا كمان مر
انتم عارفين انا كمان انا كمان انا وعيلتي
وماما فكرنا ازاي نديله حسنات في نفس
الوقت ندخل
الجنه انا رفعت ايديا وقلت انا هلبسه تاج
الكرامه لو حفظت القران كله ان شاء الله
هلبسه تاج الكرامه لو حفظت القران كله
واديني
اهو
واديني هو تخلت كورسين قران واحد تبارك
والتاني عممه وديني اهوت وديني بعمل
علاقات كتيره وانتم عارفين انا كمان مريت
بال اختبار ده
بايه انا اعلمت من الاختبار دوت حاجه اللي
هو زي مثل الشجره الشجره جذورها هي العيله
الصغننه
هي مثلا بابا وماما واخواتي والعيله
الاكبر سنه هي الاغصان هي العيله الاكبر
سنه هي خالتي وعمتي وعمي واما بقى الاوراق
هي ثالث
جزء اما بقى الاوراق هي ثالث جزء هي
الاصدقاء هي
الاصدقاء ماقدرش ما نقدرش
نعيش من غير حاجه من دول لازم نعيش بحاجه
من دول بس اهم بس اهم جزء منهم هم الجذور
اللي دايما ثابتين في الارض معانا وفي
ظهرنا دايما انا بدعي لبابا ولو سمحتوا
ادعوا له انتم
[تصفيق]
كمان